[Music]
what was your relationship with your
writers like I started out as a comedy
writer and always knew that I'd like to
perform but that's where I spent the
first seven eight years in the business
was writing and I was always I live
among the writers I aqil them I beat
them up they beat me up that's the kind
of relationship we have what kind of
relationship did you have with your
write well I didn't tackle them but I
like on Wednesdays I remember the
writers would get together for lunch and
then they would show old clips from
comedies you know from Sid Caesar and
Milton Berle and Jackie glazier classic
so this one Wednesday at lunch I went in
to talk to the head writer and I hadn't
looked you know then I'm whispering to
it and I'm hearing moaning and I looked
up and it was a porn film the writers
were watching pornography well they knew
I was coming here nothing's changed also
in comedy writing and I looked at that
no that's just terrible and Ernie said
to me Carol he is doing the best he
I want to say I hate it when I was
younger having red hair when I was a kid
I but a consolation for me was that two
extremely funny women from television
Lucille Ball and Carol Burnett had red
hair and I thought of myself as a young
woman in comedy Tommy yeah but I that
was always [ __ ] but that was that was
an accident it was I remember one time
when I would do Q&A with the audience
you know that the start of the show
loved that and then yeah cute little guy
I think it might have been about 12 and
he had this shock of red hair and
everything and he raised his hand and I
called on him and he said when you were
in school did they tease you about your
red hair yeah I said no I didn't have
red hair
well it's brown yet you're like it's
probably why yeah no I